hello hello professor Sudan yeah this is
Adam Smith calling from the Nobel Prize
website in Stockholm where it has just
been announced that you've been awarded
the Nobel Prize together with Jim
Rothman and Randy Schekman I am serious
yes my name is Adam Smith and I work for
the four noble media which is the media
company of the Nobel Foundation and the
announcement has just been made just a
very few minutes ago
here in Stockholm oh my god I I just had
the pleasure of speaking to your wife in
California who I'm afraid I probably
woke up and she very kindly gave me let
me just stop a moment here because I'm
driving in the middle of Spain somewhere
I was actually thinking that my friend
was calling me because I seem very happy
to be woken up with the news and quite a
amazing it's it's a time of award so I
mean you just a couple of weeks ago you
were in New York receiving the Lasker
Award yes yeah yeah you know I mean
there's been a lot of speculation about
this but I
and I imagine it's also very nice to be
awarded together with James Rothman and
Randy Schekman
oh it's wonderful it's wonderful I'm
actually extremely happy because I think
that's incredibly fair and you know
people and everybody has their own view
of who deserves what and one tends to
overestimate one's self but I think that
you you renowned for your productivity
what gives you the drive to work so hard
my wife thinks I'm crazy I am I am
incredibly driven I didn't think I was
when I was young I thought it was normal
but I think it older and I see the other
people around me and I feel sometimes
that that's the way I of course of
course and I guess now I guess now you
have a choice because you're on your own
in a car in the middle of Spain
somewhere you have the possibility you
have the possibility of running off and
being on your own or facing facing
everybody who wants to talk to you
well I'm supposed to give a talk with us
yes lucky Institute that has you for the
afternoon no I cannot tell you how much
I enjoy what I do so I've always
considered an enormous privilege to be a
scientist and
this is incredibly beautiful so thank
you very much my a sincere
congratulations thank you